les chers amis en tant que délégué
national aux entrepreneurs il m'a été
demandé d'aborder le sujet de
l'entreprise en deux minutes
j'irai donc droit au but je suis
moi-même chefs d'entreprise à saint
nazaire
je vais donc vous parler de réalité de
terrain ce que je mesure chaque jour
dans mon entreprise
françois hollande et manuel valls
peuvent bien prétendre dans toutes les
langues du monde qu'ils aiment
l'entreprise
c'est faux ils ont réussi au cours des
trois dernières années a déprimé les
entrepreneurs l'ensemble des acteurs de
l'entreprise et pire encore
l'ensemble du tissu économique manque de
visibilité manque de confiance
augmentation des charges augmentation
des réglementations rétropédalage tout y
passe aujourd'hui de nombreuses
personnes qui ont un talent pour créer
de l'activité et développés sont à bout
elles vous ont malheureusement deux
choix soit quitter la france soit tout
arrêter elle étouffe
elles n'en peuvent plus et la dernière
trouvaille du gouvernement valse avec la
loi rebsamen sur le dialogue social la
création des comités régionaux syndicaux
avec ses comités
les socialistes en train de servir sur
un plateau les pme et les tpe aux
syndicats le dialogue social sera alors
orchestré par des professionnels du
syndicalisme hors sol totalement
déconnecté du quotidien des pme et des
tpe
c'est une menace forte pour nos
entreprises
nous devons donc nous y opposer
fermement mais mes chers amis s'opposer
ne suffit pas à faire un programme notre
famille politique doit mettre les tpe et
les pme
au coeur de son projet économique car
non seulement c'est le poumon de
l'économie mais aussi un vecteur social
fondamental ancré dans les territoires à
nous de donner des signaux forts aux
entrepreneurs pour leur signifier qu'ils
peuvent compter sur nous alors j'en suis
certain nous pourrons compter sur eux et
ensemble recréer la croissance
nécessaire à l'emploi et à la croissance
je vous remercie